Wow.
Well,
go to your mom's house.
Christina Vincent,
Tommy,
Tommy.
Would you marry your dad?
Just like,
just like the gaze.
just like the good ways.
Just like,
just like the gaze.
just like the gays.
Would you murdered your store?
Yes,
of course.
My God.
I wish I could calm me.
Would you marry your dad?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
I would do it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Do you want to marry your dad?
Yeah,
of course.
I live for this shit.
Just like,
just like the gaze.
just like,
Just like,
just like the gate.
When you married your mom?
No,
I think I got married.
My Dad.
Yeah.
Would you marry your mom?
Hi.
No,
no.
Please.
No.
What'd you marry your dad?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yes.
Yeah,
like just like the gaze.
Just calm,
like the ways,
like just like the gays.
Awesome.
Just when do you marry your dad?
Oh my God.
That's a standing
that is a gay questions by MC fluid bond fluid.
Bonder and
it says there.
Damn,
Tami,
Tami.
Yeah.
Tommy,
is this like gays?
Would you marry your dad?
Hilarious.
Um,
that's really funny.
No,
it really just got me to thinking now is who I would choose to marry my mom or
my dad.
We did it.
We did this.
Who did I choose?
Well,
my mom's dead.
But let's say they were both alive.
Yeah.
To,
I didn't choose.
I thought you did choose Dana.
I thought so.
Who did I say?
I don't remember.
I thought this was part of,
um,
God,
they're both so fucked up.
Yeah.
Who would you marry?
My Dead Mom or my dad asked him,
will you ever date your mom?
Little known fact is that people really liked that clip and we assume because we
didn't get a lot of traffic on it through email or Twitter,
that they didn't.
But yeah.
Uh,
one listener emailed and likened it to a Yelp review that sometimes you only see
a review when there's something negative to be said.
It's a good thing.
It's,
no,
I called me mom.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And it actually,
it was a big,
yeah,
a lot of feedback after we put it out there that we didn't know.
We just didn't know if it was really hitting hard as other bits on the show.
Cause we were like,
we really would
share email as long as you're getting your emails during the show.
Always my emails come in,
we're solid.
And I was like,
would you ever date your mom?
Like you know a really well.
Do you think those are two of the dumbest people to live on earth?
On Earth ever?
Probably.
Yeah.
I mean it's so beyond anything.
Here's the thing too is that they're not dumb enough to know how to conduct an
interview.
You know like most people if they're into incest would be like Whoa,
kind.
It just,
you assume would just,
you know,
not,
not even sit down to talk about it.
There should be a level of trying to justify it.
You should have a level of shame where you're trying to conceal what you're
doing.
That's intelligence though.
That's on the market.
The market is shame,
but there are also have the intelligence to actually justify it with kind of
pretty decent logic because it's just like the gaze.
It's just like the case the case.
Yeah,
their own logic.
Yeah.
Boy,
I'll fucking turn that off now.
Not that I just,
there's emails coming in and if we just shut it down I did anyway.
Now I'll marry my mom.
This one has an emails on it to,
hold on.
Let me give it that.
So stupid.
Yeah.
I just came back off the road last night.
You've been touring constantly and you know this morning I think what's on both
of our minds is what happened to my morning dump you.
It's a great point.
Oh,
you had a really interesting story about it.
Well I did because we woke up together and we both have our coffees and then we
both take turns dumping and I had my coffee but there was no dump and there were
lots of farts.
Fart,
no dump.
And I'm like,
what's going on here?
The thing that I like mentioned it a lot.
You've talked about it quite a bit since then.
So it is just exactly like the guys.
Do you have any theories?
Can you help me on this?
Yeah,
you're dumps,
not ready,
but I usually go every morning like clockwork,
no matter what.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
you know,
I wish I could help,
but it's just not ready.
I have a theory if you're willing to hear it.
Um,
I'm willing to go wherever you're willing to take me right now,
the theory is this morning we have the Nespresso machine and we have different
flavor pods and I normally go with intense.
So,
which is a very bold,
strong flavor of coffee.
It's very strong.
And the numbers of the espresso.
Yeah.
And then Nespresso.
But this morning I went with pumpkin spice,
which is a lighter coffee.
And I think because I chose a lighter coffee,
it didn't produce the bowel movement that I desired.
It's a,
it's a reasonable theory.
It's a reasonable theory.
Um,
you could be on to something and it's interesting too.
It's a very interesting theory.
Yeah.
Well what I'm hoping to do,
cause I,
I gave up my,
I stubble Americano with a splash of half and half for the double tall soy
Latte,
which is old school for you old school.
This is the old school jam.
Yeah.
But I'm drinking with a straw to preserve the whiteness of my teeth.
Yup.
Um,
and we'll see if this produces a bowel movement,
we may have to pause a show so I can go shit in real time.
Also.
Very,
very interesting.
Well,
I feel like it's nice to involve the listeners and our bowel movement.
They don't always get to be a part of it.
Yeah.
And now,
uh,
now they are.
So hopefully,
hopefully that dump comes real soon,
you know?
Okay.
Yeah.
I might have to say p o p o Bop.
Oh
no,
that's silly.
Or we haven't even officially opened our show.
We probably should.
Gosh,
what are we doing?
Oh heavens.
Um,
let's get in there.
Let's do it.
Ready?
Let's do a jeans
and then mean you're going to make them be hand shape and it's going to rotate
on your other hands.
Palm.
Then assign like Butthole,
you're going to make a relaxed fist with the pinky side out and then you're
going to make an h handshake with the other hand and it's just going to mind
licking that bottle.
You're also gonna use some tongue action there,
so
don't bring it in.
One month into this,
Christina,
welcome to a new addiction of yours and called your mom's house podcast and we
are practicing signing.
Uh,
I want to toss your salad.
What I like is her total seriousness to it either she's totally committed.
She said it's fantastic.
It's like,
it's kind of creepy when she licks her though.
She goes,
yeah,
let me see that.
I love this girl.
She's really enthusiastic.
She's showing you dirty.
It's dirty sign language,
I think is so good thing.
That's great.
You know,
first we're going to finger spell it.
T.
A.
And.
T.
It was great about this girl though.
This is very juvenile.
Like if you were 11 and someone was like,
did I spell tank course?
Yeah.
It's just like when you learn a foreign language,
the first thing you asked for is the dirty words.
I remember going to Peru as a kid and learning like I understood a lot of
Spanish,
but all of it was Spanish.
My mother spoke,
so I'd never,
none first thing was like,
how do you say fuck in salt?
And like,
yeah,
of course.
And they tried to trick you were like all those cut my cousin's row row.
And,
and they were like,
they,
they said we had lunch or something.
They said,
Oh,
do you know how to say,
uh,
like how to ask for Ketchup?
And I was like,
no.
And they were like,
you say like go [inaudible].
And I know Brandon,
I was like,
I'm not that fucking dumb.
I know.
So they were like,
oh,
okay.
Well in their defense,
your cousins are sociopaths.
They are,
one of them is definitely not your bullshit.
Oh yeah.
Well he's a sociopath.
Sociopath.
Jeanette's wedding.
She's got those eyes.
He does have crazy.
Yeah.
Either it's foreign cousin i's or associates.
I think they might be foreign cousin eyes.
He's focused too.
And he's intense laser.
That's it.
Yeah.
Intensity,
laser focus.
Uh,
he says really?
He's a high achiever,
which a lot of them are,
but he also has a very direct sense of humor.
Yeah.
It's funny.
He makes me laugh a lot.
I really enjoy him.
Actually.
It looks through you though.
Ice Cold.
Tight.
Yeah.
He's got real crazy club was a sweet and he's a sweetheart actually that his
court.
Sure.
No,
I do.
I'm,
I'm saying he's one of those guys who puts off like,
oh shit.
Like real intense at his core.
He's a real sweetheart.
What was he like younger?
Did he strangle puppies?
No,
no,
no.
It was hurting animals.
No,
nothing like that.
No.
100%.
Yeah,
definitely not.
No shaving llamas.
No.
He was,
um,
you know,
he's kind of an Alpha male.
Yes.
And all that.
But since that,
not,
not what not hurting animals.
They're brothers.
These two boys that you spent time with now,
is he the,
is he the eldest?
He has crazy eyes and so that's why.
So maybe that's why.
And the high achiever,
they all are.
They all are,
but they have totally different personalities.
100%,
very different San household.
Um,
and then the youngest one is very much a young,
you know what I mean?
The young,
the baby,
the baby of the group.
What was his name?
The youngest is Diego.
Diego.
You've never met him
and once the sociopath.
Jorge.
Yeah.
Who's the one that told me about the pink dolphins one ways.
I love one voice.
I think he's my favorite.
He's a sweetheart.
He's a sweet guy.
Yeah,
I was doing in years.
I miss those guys.
Let's go to Peru.
So I told you it was kind of like one of the most exciting parts of that wedding
was hanging out with those dudes because they were like my,
my homeys.
Why don't you marry your mom and then you can go over there all the time.
Mary,
my mom,
but I couldn't,
you know,
I think we should plan.
Maybe we should plan a trip to pay route or a vacation where we get to meet
somewhere and see them.
That'd be fun.
I want them to go to Hawaii.
Hawaii is great.
You know why?
Why easier for us?
That's true.
That's awesome.
You always planning the trip.
That's easiest for us.
That's number one.
Aren't you happy about it?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Anyway,
back to my favorite person.
Yes.
Sweet girl.
This girl is awesome.
Yeah.
Why shouldn't a deaf people know how to sign?
Everything's,
everyone else is saying,
oh,
of course they do.
Of course they have.
That's how this is out there.
Yeah.
And then we're going to explain what it is.
Okay,
so first for no sign vagina?
Nope.
Not the vagina.
Asshole.
Nope,
not the asshole.
The tween.
Oh,
so you got a vagina?
No,
that was all.
Yeah,
I like that.
I kind of don't know where.
No goddamn thing.
There's vagina.
Not the vagina.
No asshole.
Okay.
Asshole.
No,
you go no.
And then you go between.
Nope.
Between Atta girl,
Atta girl.
So you're going to sign the,
the live long and prosper,
but on its side and when it's palm facing towards you and then you're going to
chop that a couple of times.
I like that.
That's great.
So again,
t a,
I,
n.
T,
not the vagina.
The anus between.
Thanks for watching.
Yeah.
Good girl.
She's fantastic.
I figured we do a really romantic phrase of will you toss my salad?
This is meant for you as a message.
Of course.
Are you saying that you want me to do it for Valentine's Day?
Why did you do to do it every day since I've met you,
it's never going to happen.
Never.
No,
it's never going to happen.
I mean it.
Your butthole is so daunting and Harry and Chocolaty.
Even though we have the todos now the washlet three 50 [inaudible] I don't trust
the cleanliness.
Super Clean.
It's really,
really,
why don't you run?
Run your finger along your ass crack right now.
Take a whiff cause I don't believe you
were just dressed like pops.
It's not separate.
Sure.
On your finger along the crack of your ass.
You don't need to figure your whole,
you don't want to come back with shit on your finger.
Thank you.
Yeah.
No,
I'm serious.
We do that from you right
now.
Smell which are not smell like a different times of the day.
Would you run your finger in your butt hole right now and smell it and then tell
me
what's your ass smells like?
What's your cock and balls smell like?
It's just some,
it's harmless pup play.
It's just all in eyes and suits.
Just friends hanging out.
It's like a cigar club.
It is.
It's like golfing or any other phenomena.
Cacophony.
All right,
we're back.
Um,
so what happened was,
uh,
that's a tour shirts.
Hmm?
What do they look like?
So people know what to buy when they see you.
So I'm bringing them with me everywhere.
Let's see,
I'll show you right now.
Oh,
the tour shirt.
It's like for the door.
Let me see.
Here it is.
Let's see if it
comes up.
It's the no teeth.
Oh,
very good.
I like that.
It's on its own shirt.
That's awesome.
And I like this guy that has no teeth and the five a day of Glock drew it.
Very talented,
very talented guy.
So anyways,
that was a,
a messenger dropping the very cool.
So I'll have,
I have some with me every week.
I can't like bring,
you know,
tons and tons,
but I bring it,
you physically have to pack them in a suitcase and then fly across the country
and take them city to city.
It's a better thing.
Like some people ship them first.
I should do that too.
That I don't know,
man.
You know what,
I've,
I've done that before.
The reason I'm against it is because if you ship it to the venue,
nine times out of 10,
whoever collects it doesn't know or it's outside.
No one picks it up.
I don't,
I don't think it's says it's a pain in the red sox.
You know what I'm saying?
Even traveling with them,
it's a pain in the ass.
Yeah,
of course.
Because you have an extra bag.
Yeah.
Then like every city I get to,
I have to coordinate first like,
hey man,
can I drop off this bag?
Right.
Yeah.
And then it's,
well,
I don't know.
Or what time.
And so there's that whole mess and then you're coordinating with a salesperson
to sell them and then you've got sizes.
So now you've got to bring where you don't have the excel,
you don't have els.
Then there's the settlement.
I then,
did I even tell you what happened then?
Oh Man,
I thought over the weekend,
the one of the cities,
so they count your shirts when you give them to him and then they count how many
you have at the end.
And that's how many you have left is that tells you what your money is.
So the guy did that and he like,
okay.
And then we counted the money and it was off and he's like,
he started doing like,
uh,
um,
see,
I see.
So is that right?
And we're like,
no,
that's wrong.
How much is it supposed to be?
We kept repeating the same.
No.
So I thought what he was doing was,
um,
doing the,
where you down technique,
where you,
you keep saying it and then what that person hopes for is that you go,
right.
So I just went like,
well,
I guess,
you know,
just count it again.
And then he was,
uh,
yeah,
so,
and then he kept looking around like I go like,
do you think money's laying under shirts or something?
You know,
it was just like this ongoing thing.
So I told the promoter,
I go,
I'm going to go here and talk to some friends.
You,
you handle it,
dude.
20 minutes later I went back.
He had miscounted the,
uh,
the shirts at the end.
So he was the correct amount of money was there.
Right.
But at first I really thought he was just trying to be slick with it.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing.
It's human error.
It's all small.
But you know,
it's funny because in our business there's human error all the time.
Course they give you the ticket things and at the numbers don't match.
I would say most of the time I get paid inaccurately or something's inaccurate
and yeah.
Yeah.
That's another thing,
by the way,
for all businesses.
I mean,
I had one a few,
few months ago or I finished the show and you know,
every,
for people that don't know how it works in comedy,
I mean every Gig you do has its own,
its own contract.
Yeah.
And it was like a percentage and then you knew how many tickets are involved,
right?
Like yeah,
you know exactly the price of the tickets.
So the math is really for somebody that's horrible at math it's very easy and
laid out.
So the guy was like,
you sold out.
So I'm like,
great,
that's that many tickets that's at that ticket price.
And that's the percentage.
And he goes,
guess what you made?
And I go,
I don't have to guess.
And he's like,
what do you mean Your Jab?
I go,
well there's no guessing because I know.
And he goes,
well what do you think it is?
I know,
I don't think it's something,
I know what it is.
Right.
And then I told him and he's like,
ah,
that's not what I have.
And I go,
yeah,
there's not different versions of,
of what it could be.
It is this because the deal was x number of tickets at x dollars for the results
of this percentage.
And I explained that to him.
He was like,
oh no one is going on here.
Yeah,
they never,
and they start like like calling other people and I was just sitting there,
it's exhausting and the end he was like,
you know what?
You actually had the number right now.
I of course,
man.
Yeah cause it's in the contract that we both signed months and months like no,
my favorite is I did a club where the ticket count was one thing and then the
dollar amount was another and I'm like this is so wrong.
Like it's wrong.
Well what happened was,
you know it was from the show before the numbers got mixed up and dead that it's
like
what do you,
what is this?
What business are we speaking of?
Another business.
How about the airline thing that happened to me this week.
You bought a ticket for someone.
I have the coordinating travel is a horrible,
as most people know when you're coordinating it for a tour,
like I'm doing where it's a different city every day.
It's really stressful.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and also I bring a,
an opening act and I take care of their travel.
So I reached out to management company and they were like,
well yeah,
what people do is they use a travel agent who specializes in Torin,
right?
So you go,
okay,
so I hire these people,
it's really a actually really reasonable fee.
They just put a a fee on a ticket book,
right.
And they get discount.
So you anyways,
I also get notifications on my phone when my card is used,
the credit card pops up that,
uh,
like $7,500 charge pops up on my phone.
And I was like,
Whoa,
what is that?
So I called the credit card company and they go,
Oh yeah,
it's a British Airways.
And I'm like,
well,
as much as I'd love to go to the UK,
I haven't bought anything on British Airways.
And they're like,
well,
you did now.
So they're like,
is it fraud?
I'm like,
I guess so.
Cause I didn't buy it
well.
And it's not uncommon to have fraud on our cards.
I think one time somebody in London went to like,
it's so weird,
why wouldn't card thievery happens in the UK a lot.
[inaudible] my favorite about that was that those men James
called and they,
they just asked a very nonchalantly,
they go,
hey,
did you spend,
I'm sorry Mr Seeger.
We were,
you know,
this is whatever credit card did you spend $25,000 at Christian Dior in London?
And I go,
no,
I actually did not.
They're like,
oh,
okay.
Well somebody did.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
So anyways,
it turns out not only,
uh,
there was no fraud.
The travel guy accidentally,
he's explained that like on the profiles that if he does things too quickly that
the profile doesn't like move on to the next refresh.
Yeah.
And it may explain it it and I totally believe that,
but he was like,
I had your profile up.
I then,
you know,
was done with what?
With you.
I pulled up the next person's and I had their thing ready to go and I just hit
purchase and it went,
it used your profile information for their ticket.
And then I not only was it that,
but that I bought it for a very special guy.
You're going to tell him who it is.
I mean I think he,
I think I deserve a little,
yeah,
it's Robert Pattinson.
He's a band.
Yeah.
Maybe you just bought a vampire her plane ticket cause he's team a better team.
Edward Edward.
Yeah.
All the last one I did when I found out it was for him.
I said let him keep it.
So it's a joy to purchase.
Cause are you,
you're really a big fan of those twilight movies.
I know you love them.
I go,
listen,
I've been looking at uh,
Robert for about seven,
eight years now.
Yeah.
Long enough to feel like I owe him a 70.
You really are team Edward Over Jacob though,
right?
Am I mean,
let's be serious here for a minute.
100%.
Yeah.
What do you like more about Edward Versus Jacob?
I mean,
just a here's a better knows.
Yeah,
he does Taylor Lautner kind of hassling of a wonky
kind of a like a like a button,
like a square.
Almost like a baby knows.
Yeah.
It's weird,
but it's oddly big too.
Okay.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
What else?
Oh,
was big British eyes like that jaw line,
but he Jacob's or,
yeah,
but who'd be more fun to hang out with?
That's a good,
that's a really good question.
Hey God dammit.
It's a really good question because Edwards like this educated,
he's been,
he's been alive for hundreds of years.
Yeah,
but then Jacob,
they're kind of all about the party and the fun.
They're down to earth.
They keeps it real,
so it's kind of,
hey,
come here and I'm not saying that sounds good for our show.
Come here
now.
Do you think it's good when you yell,
Hey,
come into the mic.
Come here buddy.
My heads away.
It's pretty loud.
What'd you want her to keep barking or do you want it to stop?
Hey,
do you want her to stop?
I want her to stop.
Then she stopped because I have her stay here.
Dummies?
Yeah.
Oh,
I hope I can take a shit soon.
Well,
so who are you choosing?
Team Edward or team Jacob?
I am.
I switched depending on my mood,
but Edward abandoned her.
Let's not forget.
I'm going to kill you.
I abandoned her.
And Robert and Taylor Loner.
Yeah.
Not as characters.
Not as vampires.
No.
The reason I liked him,
Edward.
Yeah,
I like him more aesthetically.
Robert.
You know why I don't really like muscular dudes.
It's not my thing.
Got It.
I don't like those big horse cocked.
Muscular fit.
Athletic looking guys.
Oh,
can you?
I'm going to rein these dogs in.
Okay,
hold on.
Okay.
Why?
What?
What's the,
I'm putting,
you're the fucking throwing shit personality champion.
Oh
God.
You're just grumpy because you're tired and you've been on the road for a long
time and your rugby.
Yeah,
but also because you won't,
you know,
but so to Davidson sign,
I'm going to say my salad.
You tossed salad mean like butthole.
Yeah.
That's my really like her.
She's fantastic.
She brightens my day.
You should tell your couple of cues from her.
So we're gonna start off with mine.
Just put your hand on your chest salad.
You're actually gonna online tossing a salad and you're going to puck your
cheats out.
So,
okay.
Um,
you,
you're going to point to the person to saying top salad.
I'm going to do the same as the sign for salad,
but slightly larger.
And I'm going to mount the word toss while I'm signing it.
So
awesome.
And then mean you're gonna make a v hand handshake and it's going to rotate on
your other hands.
Palm then decided like Butthole,
you're gonna make a relaxed fit with the pinky side out,
and then you're going to make an age handshake with the other hand and it's just
going to apply the same staff though.
You're also going to use some tongue action there.
So
awesome.
So we're gonna put it all together and say my salad,
you tossed salad mean.
Yeah,
that's,
it's so hot.
All right.
Herei.
Thanks for watching.
It's hot.
I didn't know she was going down that road.
I didn't think so.
Either.
It's hot and know what she's into now.
A little piglet.
Yeah.
She's,
she's an animal.
Not like you.
Do you think she's into tossing someone salad or having hers toss a,
I think she's into all of it.
She seems like the kind of person that would,
uh,
be done any of it.
She's really,
I mean,
look at her,
she's doing videos,
what she's doing videos about how to say,
toss it and I want to toss salad.
And she's like,
that's so hot.
I mean,
she's into it.
She's a new it.
Yeah.
Are you in to her now because of that?
Of course.
That's so attractive.
Remember there was a time where people wrote in and they were like,
I would,
I would eat Tom's asshole.
They were coming up to me at shows.
Sometimes you don't actually not sometimes I think 99% of the time it was as
couples where like the guy,
I'd be like,
go for it.
Um,
I,
uh,
I would lick your butthole.
Like she would say like,
he totally put it up her up to it or whatever I'm supposed to say.
I would look your butthole and then I would look at the guy,
he'd be like,
Oh,
okay,
thank you so much.
Special.
It does feel like a really nice thing to say to somebody.
Did it,
did it make you feel nice?
And so I thought it was like,
it was kind of like maybe,
I dunno.
I,
I felt like kind of like I was in a wheelchair and uh,
somebody goes like,
oh,
you know,
I would fuck you.
And you're like,
oh,
thanks.
Not that.
Like if you're in a wheelchair,
no one says that.
But it felt kind of like they were putting their arm around me.
Like I was the last kid picked on the team and they're like,
you can play with us.
You know,
like that is the last butthole on earth.
I would lick maybe the last
one.
Let me think.
Hold on.
Such a jerk.
I would.
Well,
I don't know.
I just,
I just know you,
you haven't smelled your,
your butt hole by the way.
Oh yeah.
I was supposed to run my finger along the crack.
You know,
it's clean right now.
Let's do it anyways.
Why?
Cause I want to verify my belief that I think even if even if you do wash,
I feel like an hour later it just gets gaming game here throughout the day.
Of course.
But right now it's not.
That's sure.
Go ahead and I would it be right now.
Listen,
if you have a minute,
if you have a moment,
I'm busy.
I'm doing this show,
right?
Right.
Your Day.
Just run your finger along your crack.
There's no need to put your finger in your ass hole.
You don't want to get shit on your finger.
It sounds like I don't have to press the button anymore.
That's true.
Um,
where are you going to do it or not?
No,
I'm not a fucking,
how are we going to move towards this goal if you don't reassure me that it
doesn't smell bad.
It doesn't smell bad.
It doesn't,
but you're not reassuring me while you run your finger along my crack.
The,
I don't want to smell it doesn't smell.
I need you to verify that it smells to it doesn't smell.
Okay Babe.
I showered,
shower.
Does it matter after the doe?
Does it matter?
Yeah,
it does matter.
Of course it matters now because you're gross.
Everything's gross all the time.
Oh my God.
So much going on politically.
Um,
and uh,
what am I,
you know,
I love hearing the different perspectives on all the issues.
Um,
this is one that I very much captivated by
building the wall.
Tell y'all the wall was coming.
We're going to keep them motherfuckers out.
We'd run the industry map,
go and follow.
Look smart.
Steve Lobbied Bill
as we build as well around the instrument.
Looks up,
we hear baby.
Absolutely fantastic.
Uh,
this is just a black guy in a blonde wig with a blue coat and a red tie and he's
little Trump.
I Dunno.
What's he selling?
What's does it look what's saying?
Oh No,
just followers.
That's why I think I don't understand is like what's the cell?
Yes.
Makes me so happy.
I saw it on the street watchers page on Instagram and uh,
I don't know exactly what I love so much about how,
just how simple.
First of all the outfit is,
you know,
that he was just like,
okay,
I'll be Trump.
How so?
Well,
I'll put on a red tie and I'll put on a blonde wig.
We're going to talk about the wall.
I'm just going to pick up two bricks and that he's essentially just saying,
I'm Trump.
I'm little Trump because I got a wig basically right now.
Horrible Blonde Wig.
It's really fucking funny and it's also just go out to the front line and we'll
just go on the front row.
We build a wall baby,
and they said we're going to keep,
the month is out.
Absolutely love it.
I've watched it over 40 Oh,
I know when you've been repeating it over and over.
No told y'all the while was cut.
We don't keep the motherfuckers out.
We run the industry now.
I don't know.
That's why I don't understand any of that.
We've run in the end.
We are baby
boom.
Follow the swamp.
Steve Wabi Bill.
Okay.
See the wealthy follow history be on this wall around the industry.
Around the anime industry.
Huh?
Okay.
Well that's what I'm saying.
Is this guy in it for the social media glory.
Well,
Dylan,
I mean the way he's talking,
it sounds like,
you know the way like a rapper would talk.
We're,
we're taking over the industry.
Sorry,
where's your water?
Where's your water?
It's over here.
It's under the table.
Oh is it?
Let's see that because I'm looking and I don't see you having any water.
It's interesting cause I'm sipping on my scissors.
Let me finish the trouble because there's also a refreshing of Trump at the
White House having breakfast
only in a matching.
You get to eat like this little low huddle house.
You have to be invited to match a need like this.
This is how we do it every day baby.
This is how we live.
Yeah.
And you mentioned baby in the medicine.
I Dunno why he maintains a mansion as opposed to the White House shore.
The best part of this clip is that that is,
you know,
presumably where it would end.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They just keep rolling right and cut and no one knows what to do.
So the guy's just staring at the camera.
It's a nice house though.
Yes.
Great.
Nice breakfast for sure.
Sure.
It's got orange juice,
coffee,
milk,
and orange slices too.
I liked that too.
The CEO Georgia mug.
Yeah.
Waffle.
I mean money from the food back to the guy.
Yeah.
The guy still puts his fork and knife.
Make sense?
Yeah.
I don't know what that means is in a robe with his bond.
Well,
they've got the flag there.
That's good cop work.
Yeah.
All right.
Just let them eat,
man.
Yeah,
that's good.
When it's like that going to,
he's putting the yolk with the potatoes.
It really good.
Well,
I don't find that one is hilarious as you do.
I like it,
but I'm not like,
lol.
Thanks so much.
And I think we agree to disagree on that one.
Okay,
well I'm just saying,
all I'm saying is if you're looking for maybe a unique perspective on the
political situation,
maybe little Trump is the way to go crossfire
next week.
Yeah.
Yes.
So that's,
that's just,
I don't know.
That's just my opinion.
Okay.
Um,
now one thing that we haven't visited in a while is I'm coaching.
I love coaches with a message and this is a little league coach,
a little league baseball coach,
and it's pretty intense how he talks to children playing
baseball.
I want to make it,
this is our last night,
Aiden.
Eyes on me.
89 on me.
You'd have to say eyes on me.
You know,
near not interested.
Of course they're kids.
How old you think these kids are?
Make sure you guys remember what our goals are when we step on this field.
Jackson,
we're the next.
What's one of our goals when we stepped on the field
to do your basket?
You're not even close.
Hey,
great.
Yeah.
Good coach.
Good to do your bestest.
Not even close.
Well,
that's not the super relative best and the way that they're,
that kid,
his voice just sounded,
I'm guessing six or seven.
Is he eight?
Yeah.
Our goals are to hit dingers.
Everybody better have their eyes on me.
Eyes on me.
Reiland hitting or disgrace.
The pictures.
Family,
the other families,
other players cry like this.
Dump their buds into the crowd.
Does everyone understand that?
Yes.
I like this pretty great.
I would have Ellis play with this guy.
Yeah.
This is real life shit.
I like.
I agree.
You know,
because doing,
you're just doing your best is really not good life advice.
Yeah,
because it's not really the point.
The point is to win.
Yeah.
We're losing sucks.
I know.
You should always teach your children that.
I'll take him out of any participation award should get the fuck Outta here with
that or merit awards.
I used to get a bunch of those too.
Yeah.
There are two types.
There's two types of people in this room.
There's winners and there's losers.
Just so that we're clear.
Every time we step on this field,
our goal is to be a winner.
Yup.
There you go.
How many teams?
How many parents got in infuriated by this?
I'm sure.
A lot speech.
Yeah.
Well they're losers,
so they would,
that's right.
Yeah.
I like this guy
and if your dad,
he said,
oh,
it doesn't matter whether you win or lose just as long as you have fun.
Yeah.
Hate to say it.
Your Dad's a loser.
Yeah,
I agree with coach right about that.
I agree with that.
Especially at this age.
Yeah.
I mean you want to,
what is it,
the peewee league.
Oh yeah.
This is fucking really early.
Be Dominate that shit.
Yeah.
You got to teach them that losing sucks losing sat.
Okay.
Seriously?
I believe.
Well,
I think this horse shit that you should just have fun.
Like no,
actually when you're playing a competitive sport,
it's not about having fun.
No.
If you wanted to just have fun,
you wouldn't play a game.
Right.
You would go out and rally or what a volley or whatever.
Like in tennis you don't play for for score.
Yeah.
But you're scoring.
So yes,
you may as well fucking trying to win loser is to try to score more.
That's real.
Yeah.
So then that's why there's a scoreboard.
Dip Shit.
You're fucking dumb.
Shit.
Dummy.
Dumb Dumb Shit,
motherfucker.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
This guy is spot on now.
If that was excellent.
Yeah,
that was great,
man.
I remember those coaches.
Men.
I do.
Yeah,
of course.
That's how we were raised.
That's,
you know,
gen Xers and gen wires.
That's how we were raised.
And then,
you know,
now it's all fucking pussified.
Nobody talks to kids.
Nobody tells kids a truth anymore about life.
Everything's sugarcoated.
And these poor fools have no clue what's happening when they go out in the real
world.
You know,
there's,
uh,
it's unfortunate for them.
I'm not criticizing the kids.
It's not their fault.
It's the adults who have failed them.
There's a lot of leaks like that now where they go,
everybody gets a trophy.
I mean,
that's a big serious,
absolutely.
Everybody gets a trophy for just showing up.
Everybody gets a trophy leaks.
Yes.
There are kids not on those,
you know that.
No,
of course not.
And that's never going to happen in my world.
No.
Why would you get a trophy just for doing it world.
The world doesn't reward you.
They don't want anyone's feelings to get hurt.
Yeah,
that's true.
God forbid a kid would,
you know,
I,
I can't even get into it.
Hurt feelings are what motivate you to change and do better.
Of course if you never get your feelings hurt,
then you never realize what you're doing.
What makes you want to work harder?
Of course.
Yeah.
And you learn to deal with loss as a child.
That's number one.
Everybody else get the trophy.
I want the trophy.
Then you work hard and then you figure it out.
Yeah.
But to not even let the kid feel the feeling of failure.
I'm a good luck in life,
asshole.
Cause it's all failure and then you win some,
right.
Life is so much failure.
Yeah,
of course.
It's about,
it's about recovery.
Resilience.
Yeah.
And what a fucking dumb lesson we're teaching these kids to give everybody a
trophy just for showing up.
Good luck.
That's fucking retarded.
That makes me so mad.
Does he mad?
I think it's silly.
Like a old lady.
Fuck that.
Good luck.
Okay.
I'm turning into a,
you said yesterday I was turning into a Midwestern mom.
You're such a Midwestern cause I think,
uh,
as long as I haven't said awesome sauce yet.
And I feel like once I say that you were just like,
oh my God,
that's my jam.
That's my jam and I'm like,
okay.
Oh my goodness.
That's my jam.
I don't know.
It was something that maybe we're eating or ordering or something.
You're like,
oh,
that's totally my jam.
I ain't telling him I just have to start wearing cool.
Lot's pretty soon.
You're such a mom.
I mean,
no,
it's all good.
It's fine though.
I like it.
Your total dad,
this morning we were playing with Lj.
You had on your boxer shorts.
They were there now paper thin and you've been wearing them around our nanny,
which is really neat.
Thanks for doing that.
The slippers even imply.
That sounds like you're being sexual.
I don't mean sexual.
That's what it sounds like that all around our nanny,
like I didn't hear that.
You heard that.
People hear that.
Oh yeah,
no.
What I meant was no regard for her visual assault.
The point is is that you're not putting on pants,
not because you think it's sexy,
but it's just disrespect.
She doesn't want to see you're a dick and balls hanging out of your,
your shorts.
Yeah.
Okay.
What?
Nothing.
God,
let me put this on.
Oh my God,
this show today.
What fallen off the rails?
How's it falling off the road ringing and the barking and the t shirt
deliveries.
That's all right.
No problem with you as you're there.
The point is,
do you think,
I mean,
why don't you put on pants?
It's weird that you just walk around in your underwear.
I Dunno.
I'm comfortable and I'm home.
I want to wear my boxers.
So do you think she,
she probably notices it,
but she's too polite to say anything.
Of course you notice it?
Yeah,
but she's probably also like,
ah,
I have three boys.
Three boys,
three boys.
So she's seen all the cock and balls.
Now how are we going to find out or not?
Yeah.
I want you to put your finger down there.
You're supposed to get a step closer.
It's not me.
Yours smells though.
Yeah,
but I want you to leave.
It's not sexual.
We're just doing pup play.
I just need you to put on a dog mask in a latex outfit.
Okay.
You also burp and fart relentlessly around her?
No,
I don't think Guatemalan nanny.
she has to be a few rooms away,
but for me to do it,
I'll do it.
The other day I was coming home with Ellis and she was already at our house.
Yeah.
And I was,
uh,
I didn't,
you know,
she,
I saw her in the kitchen as I was pulling in the driveway,
and I go in and get Ellis and the car seat.
I'm taking him out and I just rip a huge fart just,
and she's right there to tell you,
hi,
Miss Christina.
Oh Shit.
She heard me Fart.
You're fart.
But she farts to that,
which she doesn't Fart in front of us,
but she farts.
She's a person I,
yeah.
Yeah.
And she's probably heard a lot of fire.
It's just three boys too.
Oh yeah.
It's all farts in Cox involves paints.
Yeah,
of course.
But no one farts like you,
so that's true.
I'm sure she's not used to whatever you did for her.
Remember last night when I farted and I forgot that I had farted and then I
smelled it and I got startled and I was like,
fart it.
Yeah.
Oh,
smells.
Yes.
Why do you keep saying it?
It's so gross.
Why do you keep repeating it and keep telling these stories?
They're so terrible.
Was terrible.
The story and why no one wants to hear that about what about this far?
It's,
and you're shitting in your farm.
Everybody wants to be,
this whole show is about farting shit and calming and Ah,
do you mean it's good?
I wish you would anyway.
I thought it was really neat the other week you and I discovered something that
we both hate together and which is very rare because we've been for 12
years.
Yeah.
And just when we thought we discovered everything we mutually hated.
We discovered one more thing,
which is Frank Sinatra.
Yeah.
I'm not entertained.
I don't think it's great.
It's also not singing.
Why do you say that?
He's singing,
he's not singing [inaudible] sing like him.
De de de,
De,
de la,
la La pop,
pop,
pop.
Hey Ya da Da da da.
Hey.
No,
no,
no.
But what about it
Maslow?
Yeah,
I guess he kind of things that one,
but most of it is like I'm walking in,
there's ladies at the bar,
but a prop man bring me a drink and la La la,
and you're like,
that's not really singing,
man.
You're just kinda like,
uh,
raising the pitch of your talking voice.
Yeah.
I,
yeah.
A lot of the songs are,
I like that.
That's singing.
Yeah.
Celebrating.
It's a bebop scared of the dark date.
Yeah.
I think what bothers me about it is that it's such like it's such a chauvinist
stick.
Well,
yeah,
it hearkens apart.
Right?
That's doesn't probably,
you love the boots.
Yeah.
It's such like a Douche be a Douchey chauvinistically thing.
If you're the way have to weigh way into Sinatra,
it means that you have that.
You love that way of like,
yeah.
Back when the women did everything they should be doing,
but I don't have a problem with that at all.
Right.
Hey,
feel like it's good music.
Hey listen.
I was like,
I love listening to him.
I'm like,
really man,
like that's your favorite music.
I think he,
it just annoys me.
I don't like the,
I don't know.
I don't irritates me.
It's always kind of irritated me.
But if I had to be honest,
I'd rather hear Sinatra then Springsteen.
Wow.
Me Too.
I agree.
Springsteen annoys the shit.
I do like the song born in the USA though
because I think till like two,
like a Springsteen fanatic.
That's like a laughable one.
Well,
oh,
I mean like to them it's the flagship song yet.
Well,
I don't know many.
All I know is that this is,
oh,
hometown.
Hometown.
So annoying.
Oh,
oh,
it's
horrible.
It's the knowing part is how many people celebrate.
Like it's wonderful.
I don't understand.
That's,
I was actually,
we had this conversation maybe on,
on this show,
it was either on the show or it was off the shelf,
but it was with Paulette Tompkins.
Yeah.
Where we talked about Springsteen.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I can't remember.
We were recording or not and he said,
I think he put it perfectly.
He said that people,
you see people having an experience yeah.
With,
with like,
uh,
music or something.
Right.
So in this case,
let's say with his music and then you digest it and you go,
yeah,
I'm not sharing that.
I don't get that experience that you're having.
Yeah.
Yes.
And I think too with Spring magnitude of his,
yeah.
Following your like,
I think that's why I feel more lost by it,
cause I'm like,
I don't even understand why 10 people are into this.
Yeah.
I think it's cultural.
As was Sinatra with Springsteen,
with Lady Gaga,
with any music.
Mariah Carey,
we were watching a show about her.
If you identify with it on some level,
it resonates with your experiences in life.
Then you're like,
I get it.
Fucking hoes job from Springsteen.
Is that he's the blue collar guy?
Well,
not anyone.
Certainly he's a multimillionaire.
Yeah.
Beyond the working class guys.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Not Anymore.
He hasn't been working class 1940 years.
Yeah.
And he's singing about,
yeah.
What about about trucks and wheat farms or whatever?
Ooh.
You know who else?
Yeah.
Now you didn't shut eye.
You did it.
I don't hate him.
I don't hate,
I don't like Bob Dylan.
You and I both don't like that switch I'm going to have is good.
We don't like that
horrendous.
You won a Nobel prize this year.
Last year for the musics,
he won literature,
Nobel prize for his songwriting.
Wow.
She's had in the bag.
Oh boy.
That's irritating.
Nobel prize.
That's fucking horrible.
I don't like that.
I don't think,
I don't like acoustic music in general.
That is my least favorite genre.
Uh,
gimme a man or a woman in a guitar and I want to blow my brains out.
I don't want to hear,
I don't want to hear nothing like that.
I don't like that at all.
I mean,
maybe it was the age too.
It's two email for me.
When Eric Clapton did that one album,
he did I think an acoustic strangers in heaven.
Oh,
got it.
That album,
that album,
and that song was great.
I liked it.
It makes me too sad.
Well,
it's a superset,
so his son passed away.
Did that,
it bums me out too much.
It's so much of a white bomber.
It's still a,
it's still a good song.
Oh Man.
Then the people,
when I started announcing how much I hate Springsteen,
I would get these messages and they're like,
have you tried this?
And they're just trying to like,
I don't want to.
So then I go,
you know what?
I should try it,
dude.
I tried staying in it.
Still hate it.
Yeah.
I feel that way about you too.
And I know I'm going to get a lot of heat on my,
uh,
my trainer was like,
we're going to go,
we're driving a Vancouver wherever.
We're going to Vancouver to see you too.
And I,
you know,
she's really selling it to me,
like,
are such a great band.
And I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Like I didn't have the heart to tell her,
I just don't like them.
And I was like,
you know,
objectively I get it again,
it was all these objectively get it.
She's like,
well,
maybe you should see them live.
And I was like,
I don't think so.
I think I've said it's a prep prep day.
The more,
I think actually a huge punishment for me.
Would it be to go see like the e street band live?
Oh,
is that the,
is that,
is that the worst thing for me?
I'm saying for what I could be like,
I,
I watched their entire hall of fame induction.
I was like,
just,
I couldn't roll my eyes any harder.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I,
I watched,
I watched all these concert footage people sent me.
I am,
I have zero the e street band or Bruce Willis is blues band.
Well,
honestly,
I would Steven see gals,
blues band,
I would probably go see so golf first just because I'm so amused by him.
Okay,
well then let's change that.
Yeah.
Bruce Willis and his blues band or the East street band.
And you got to say for the whole show,
you got to take your seat.
You got to watch every song.
Well,
I already have disdain for the e street band.
Okay.
So I would at least go into Willis has banned like,
well,
you know,
maybe I'll,
maybe I'll be an entertainer.
Let's do Sinatra.
Yeah.
Or e street band.
Go.
Mm.
I would see Sinatra.
Okay.
Wow.
So,
okay.
Uh,
east street band or are you too oh,
definitely.
Go see you said you like them?
No,
I mean I like them enough that they don't have,
I'm not like a fan where I have all their shit but like him enough and I bet
it's a really good show.
I put the,
I mean like show wise.
What about metal death metal or east street band e street band.
I hate death metal.
Yeah.
That's rough.
What do,
wait,
what would you choose?
I mean I think eastern band just because a death metal show would give me so
much it would shut me down.
What about personal death?
Metal or youtube?
Uh,
you too.
Cause that's the show like you said,
like at least it's a,
they put on a grand.
What about you two or you before you had to say to you 40.
Yeah,
I know you hate it.
And they play red,
red wine,
right?
They open and close with and close with red,
red wine.
God dammit.
Now that is a tough one.
Yeah.
I hate both of them a lot.
How about I hate red,
red wine.
That's how much you hate that.
So.
Absolutely.
I love that song.
That's so funny to me.
It doesn't seem like the kind of song where somebody could feel those emotions.
You know,
it doesn't seem like it to me.
But you also have a colder personnel.
It's true.
You know what I hate about red red wine?
I'll tell you why.
The one part,
cause first of all,
it is a remake of a reggae song.
Yeah.
And the fact that it's too fucking dorky white English guys doing it infuriates
me,
number one.
And then there's the rap part of the song.
Yeah.
But
because I feel like it's a fake reggae breakdown.
It's not that.
It's not like a teacher doing around.
Yeah.
You know,
geometry or something.
Yeah.
It's a fake flavor.
It's art.
It's triangle.
Oh fuck.
But like when they do connect with the kids,
write a rap about safety first guys.
Yeah.
You got to look both ways before crossing the street.
Yes.
Super.
Super lame,
Bro.
I don't like it.
Oh,
you know what else we both hate?
southwestern things.
Oh,
thematically,
anything sounded like the aesthetic theme of like,
Oh,
this is a southwest decor.
No,
it's interesting that we both really don't like that.
That's one of the fusion Rez.
I'm not interested in at all.
Anything southwestern.
I don't like southwestern tastes like,
like their food even.
And I've had it a lot because I've been through those regions.
I don't like their version of Mexican food.
It's too different for me.
I don't like,
I like soap a PS.
I do like those.
I will say that.
Oh,
I hate that shit.
This Palo fuck that pillow.
Yeah.
What is it about fuck this shit.
Terrible.
I hate this room.
I want to set it on fire.
I fuck.
I hate it.
Oh,
look how ugly that is and know what fucking hate is called Navajo.
No,
but I mean like doing that like that as a,
making a pattern.
Like,
isn't there like a theme dude?
I'm selling wilted.
Is that,
you know what I mean?
It's like a,
yeah,
a tapestry tap.
Is that what that's called?
I Dunno.
That's not southwest son thing.
You know what?
I really hate our fucking dream.
Catchers like this is like,
oh no.
You know what I hate most horns,
horns or lamps and like a dream catchers.
Imagine every home
downtown Albuquerque.
I've been there.
I have,
I,
I found the show down there,
that hitchhiker show.
I spent a while in Albuquerque.
I think I actually want to go do a show in Albuquerque.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's good.
Um,
but then just tell him how much I hate come.
That is garbage.
Do that for 10 minutes.
I just want to tell you how much I hate the way things look here.
I don't like turquoise either.
The stone,
I don't know.
I feel like southwest,
um,
like style for Bolo tie string ties.
Hello.
Think so.
I hate those fucking suck.
Yeah.
Now the people are wonderful.
Yeah,
we're not,
I'm not putting down the,
you know,
it's just this,
the style.
I'm not interested.
Yeah,
that is interested.
That is a dog shit.
Look that tie.
That is horrible.
Terrible.
Bolo.
Bolo tie this thing to this garbage.
It has that bullshit design on the pendant.
It's all like Navajo stuff.
Fucking terrible.
I mean,
oh God got
really bad.
Oh,
you're right.
It is like Navajo.
It's Indian stuff.
I'm sorry.
Native American.
Sorry.
Native.
Well guess what?
Natives native.
He's got full neck tats and the bullet.
Well you see that's when you're a Badass.
He's a white boy.
Yup.
Actually no,
this is a total hipster.
Yeah.
Hipster that has adopted the Bolo Western style.
Like he's rocking you pull it off.
Yeah.
It was quite doing it.
It's really ugly.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
I think I would prefer that we had,
uh,
not just massacred the people,
but that style too because that's really bad.
When we handed them the blankets full of the POCs,
we should have also ripped their bolo ties off their fucking stupid fucking tie
off.
Yeah.
Really.
I'll give me your fucking dream catchers too.
I don't like it.
It's not cool.
It's neat though to find things you mutually hate apple.
I don't know if we hate anything quite that much together.
Southwestern's our big one.
I know we both hate,
I mean we have different preferences in shows and we will,
we'll find that's when it's exciting to watch a show together because separately
we have watched last night at watch that kidnapping.
Did you learn anything?
Yeah,
it was really fucking intense.
But how to kidnap or how to be a hustle.
I watched the first episode of that,
uh,
hostage to show it on Netflix.
It was about,
uh,
the Lucasville prison riots and how the prisoner took over and held the guards
captive and it was mainly,
that doesn't happen a lot.
It's so terrifying what happened there.
And they have so much footage and photos of it and the,
and the testimony that um,
you can't help but be,
you realize that has to be literally one of the worst imaginable things is what
happened there,
which is super,
super violent guys.
I'm like the worst of the worst guys take over a prison.
They murdered a bunch of like,
like it was a bunch of retaliation that,
you know,
like scores were settled amongst prisoners first,
then they,
which is interesting that they prioritize that way.
So you mean to tell me they kidnapped the guards?
Well,
at first they couples,
couple guards were like beaten down and then within moments one of the prisoners
got to the control board,
opened all the,
the,
you know,
whatever the cells,
and they started riding up in the midst of the riot.
Prisoners were killing other prisoners.
Right?
Like they're like that guy wanted to do something.
Now you'd think that your priority is a prisoner when there's a moment is to
escape that you would go,
look,
the buttons have been pushed.
We're at the control,
but,
well,
yeah,
it's interesting.
I mean,
yeah,
they,
they murdered nine other prisoners were murdered within this
prison and then they kinda,
they tied up the guards and then they had like a list of demands and the
prisoner,
the prison was trying to negotiate with them.
Here's one thing that was interesting.
There's a manual that the,
uh,
prison has about how to negotiate with prisoners if there's ever a situation
like this and the prisoners found it.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're kidding.
So they were the negotiator that the prisoner that the prison used,
like the actual prisoner reading the manual.
Hilarious.
And knew when they were doing tactics.
Um,
anyways,
so they're trying to stall because the whole idea of the negotiation tactic that
the administration was using was to basically break them down.
So they cut off electricity,
cut off the water,
and it was like,
wear them down.
That's how you'll win this negotiation.
Hm.
The guy goes,
I know what you're doing.
They have all the wow 40 calls.
And he's like,
I know what you're fucking doing.
Stolen and saying my name over and over.
I know that shit it,
and then he said like,
if you don't fucking like whatever,
meet this demand in three and a half hours,
we're going to kill a guard.
And Oh my God,
uh,
at the,
whatever the administration,
the police didn't believe him and they were like,
we got to do it.
So they killed a guard.
Whoa.
And then they tossed his body out on the,
on the yard.
Shit,
I just asked that.
But then you know,
these guys,
the other guys that didn't get killed,
the guards,
they were held captive there for nine days.
Imagine that.
Well,
like hardcore pedophiles,
murderers,
rapists,
really,
really savage dudes.
And he said like the mine stuff,
like the mind games,
like one guy had an aluminum bat and he would just tap it on the ground.
He was like,
we're going to split your head all over that.
And he would tap it at different rates to kind of,
you know.
Yeah.
There's not enough money in the world to get me to work in a prison.
Oh,
I know.
I'd,
I'd rather collect,
I don't know,
dirty diapers.
I'd rather smell your butt all day.
Yeah.
And that beam God,
this water so good.
Where's your water?
I kind of feel like that.
Last few moments have been so entertaining that we need to find something
boring.
Where's your water?
You know,
where's your water
language from?
An international continues to ship screen saver machines all around the world.
We recently delivered a screen saver Max machine to one of our newest customers.
True concrete solutions located in Michigan.
What is unique about this delivery is that most of our customers take a somewhat
more these boring videos with our new machine fighters.
Sean Richardson has extremely hard working crew of seven guys.
The voiceovers buying us.
They decided that they would take the Lord in the screen saver Max machine in
place.
1400 yards of concrete.
Oh my God.
I'm going to kill my daughter feet the first day of machine delivery and an
additional 30,000 square.
Okay,
we got it.
You got it?
I got it.
It's fucking boring.
Well,
I'm not bored.
No.
Boom.
Operated high production screen saver.
Max Machine approved.
Kriens same machine for this massive agricultural pit job.
The 4,500 pounds Max arrived at the job site.
Trailer competent,
allowing the guy into the pit on a fan based ramp that would have been
prohibitive to a machine delivered on a semi truck truck.
I can't combination.
Thank you,
Tom.
We can shut it off now.
Okay,
well it's just,
you know,
sometimes you don't believe that something could be wrong.
Boring.
We'd like to dig it up.
Find it for you.
Look Kuboto 35 horsepower diesel engine combined with the considerable screen
has done,
boom,
operated machine resulted in handling slumps that ranged from three to six
something too.
We had the um,
the you that thing you emailed me.
I should bring that up.
Yes.
Oh my God.
It's so great.
Well,
there's two things I emailed you that I want you to play.
Yeah,
that's right.
The first one.
Oh yeah,
you got it.
Dad boner.
Yeah.
So good.
So great.
It was sent in a few times.
So people really like this one.
This is so good.
We've been,
you know,
we've been doing dad Boehner clips for awhile.
Well,
glass and dads.
Yeah,
glad it all started with glasses,
glass.
And um,
now we have,
uh,
a dad that is glassing
about the train,
about this specific train.
This is from really excited.
Yeah.
I mean listen to how excited.
Ah,
I've been waiting for this moment for months and it's finally here
by the way.
It's just right now he's seeing a train about to leave a train station.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's,
that is all he seen.
So as the bell is ringing,
like it's about to take off.
Ah,
AH,
probably going to get a heritage unit on camera.
Yeah.
Oh,
look at that.
1953 eight.
Oh yeah.
Listen to that bell.
Yeah.
Alyssa,
that bell.
Oh,
take a look at that.
Oh my God.
She's beautiful.
All by
all
the SNC 52.
Oh my God.
Oh,
we're going to watch this.
this is Sabash all this a smash off.
Well,
it gives me the chills.
Not chills,
have absolutely nothing to do with how cold it is here.
But that doesn't stop a foamer.
Especially when it comes to heritage equipment.
Ah,
this is fantastic.
This is so horrible.
Oh my goodness.
I would rather that I would cry
to make you sleep with this guy.
Oh No.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I would love that to happen.
You know,
like,
just as punishment.
Oh,
fuck.
Got Super Funny.
As really crazy.
It's good to have something to get the stoke about,
you know?
Yeah.
He's um,
he's really stoked.
Stoked.
Hmm.
Um,
I don't get that excited about anything in life.
I love on these dads get super pumped about dumb shit.
I know.
So we've had whale guy cut him loose and of course our hunter at first.
Um,
yeah,
the hunter guy.
Who was the other one?
I'm glassing.
No,
no.
The other one.
There's a new one.
Last week I had my brain has gone there.
You the whales,
the whales.
We talked the wells and that was,
it was after that.
Uh,
I don't remember now.
You don't remember?
I don't remember anymore.
Oh my bro.
I have mom brain,
I forget what I even solar eclipse that distillery.
That's what it was.
Oh yeah,
no,
the diamond crowning.
Oh my God.
Little streamers look at the column to the prominence.
Prominences
prominence is leading the Chroma.
The train guy.
Steamers seemed,
uh,
I think to be even way more excited than any of these other dads.
Yeah.
He really lost his load,
seeing those boring ass training and hearing the horn because here's the thing.
And then he tried to come up with like a,
a sports caster is called about it and he was like,
the chills.
I have nothing to do with the weather outside like that.
That's what,
you know,
like a broadcast extra dad flavor on it.
Yeah.
I think the,
and also for me personally,
I understand getting excited about an eclipse or the whales or catching a moose
hunting and moose.
But yeah,
the train was kind of like,
okay bro,
you ain't seen trains before?
Well he's obviously a train enthusiast.
Yes.
Yeah.
Really fucking likes trains.
It's ridiculous.
So great.
Um,
yeah,
there's,
I love these excited dads.
I know.
I like it too.
I like,
oh,
it's just glass and quick.
Just glass.
Glass,
glass caught a moose.
He please play.
Oh,
okay.
Twitter today.
Yeah.
I've been dying.
Listen to it again.
Yeah.
There's this guy.
I wanted to save the excitement about it,
so you guys know that the hey mommy and thanks genes obviously have been hugely
popular.
Uh,
we get literally fucking dozens every day.
It's a movement.
Yeah.
Um,
but today a guy sent in one and a,
and I'm trying to pull this up.
Here it is here.
This guy is in a car,
his name is jet ski.
Jeff and he's in an Uber Uber and he decides to just use like show topics,
like little talking points in his conversation with the Uber driver.
It's so ridiculous.
And with volume
there hindsight and uh,
we're just going to go,
uh,
we're going to go golf.
You know what I mean?
We're going to do them.
Hitler.
We're going to do it for him.
We're going to do it for Hitler.
So crazy.
If you're the driver to hear that there were going to do for Hitler.
One time my mom asked me if she would,
she told me she,
it is what it is.
I guess this is so not true.
My favorite part of that,
part of the thing is just that he's eating and he's just like having,
my mom was like,
Yo,
what'd you date me?
I was like,
oh,
maybe I would say my mom,
you know?
No,
I was like,
maybe I would do
it is what it is.
And she wanted somebody who was a little too hard,
absolute nonsense.
Gibberish.
It's like,
what are you talking?
Oh,
okay.
But one of the main things we love doing the Jersey is pup play.
It's not like a sexual thing,
but like people just like Joseph,
like dogs.
It's fun.
It's a lot.
She said it's one a day,
one a day.
There's a lot of pup play going on.
I'm like,
no,
we're dressed up like dogs and we'll just see how it just have fun.
Sometimes you gone come runs.
It's a core part of the public.
It is what it is.
You figure out who's,
who's the most line tight,
who's the most hydrated and it's
wow.
Yeah,
it's back here.
She's telling you this is what we use
story for sure.
Yeah.
It's just like what this guy was talking about.
Camera says again,
date his mom
do,
they're in Jersey.
Yeah.
Stay hydrated.
That's what we do.
We're at top golf right now and uh,
we're just gonna,
we're gonna glass here.
It's so ridiculous.
Really Great.
Jeff.
Good job.
Jet Ski Jaffa had us laugh and that really made us laugh hard.
He's like,
you know,
one day my mom,
she,
I was like,
oh,
maybe I would,
you know,
ask them,
will you ever date your mom?
Um,
wow.
This water is so fresh and clean.
Where's your water?
You keep asking.
A bunch came in.
Oh,
hi mommy.
Thanks jeans.
You want to see something?
Yeah,
of course.
Okay.
Favorite segment.
Good morning.
Welcome to Starbucks.
Can I get any recommend filling for you today?
Hi Mommy.
I'm glass and God blesses him Nigga.
You know what I'm doing what I'm saying.
Can I get,
um,
a succulent Chinese meal?
Shouts out to your mom's house and a high and tight Combo Macchiato with an
extra shot of Stan.
Emma,
please.
I'm sorry.
Can you repeat that please?
I didn't understand that.
Oh,
I need a total Carmel Macchiato with an extra shot of Brown.
An extra shot of espresso.
Espresso.
Yeah.
Haha Yada.
With an extra shot of espresso.
And what else are we getting for you?
This is pretty low and loose,
but can I get this,
the kid temperature please?
Because I got some sensitive chompers.
Okay.
So let's [inaudible] with an ad shot at kid's temperature.
Yeah,
that's correct.
Anything else?
That's it.
Thank you.
Jeans.
I'll see you here.
Thank you.
That was fuck man.
Well,
the game is the Game Evelyn Evelyn elevates was Stan [inaudible] who was
standing.
Yeah.
Every week.
Every week it gets higher and higher.
The game,
the game is always evolving.
Yeah.
That was like wow.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Wow.
And I thought getting a hate Hitler and there was controversial on me too,
man.
And he threw in and God blesses,
you know,
it sounded like you,
uh,
that was,
that was Corey Corey.
Good work.
Hey look,
can I get the loaded breakfast?
Which I can make that conduct.
Uh,
you know what?
I'm just glassing so can we just keep just the Burrito?
You know what?
I am going to get a medium coke zero.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
you know what,
can you make that a large,
I've got a really bad bite.
Yeah.
Make it a large,
um,
uh,
this sound kind of weird,
but are you guys hiring right now?
We're taking application for snag a job.
Oh yeah.
You have stuff.
Is that online?
Yes,
it is.
Do you have stuff online like on Facebook or Linkedin?
I know if you go to snag a job,
like at parties out there and you walked her into that.
Okay,
good.
It goes.
Oh,
I see.
I was looking,
I know linkedin is helpful,
so I'm sorry.
I know that was random.
Uh,
sorry.
Can you read that back to me?
A fucking camp.
You know what,
just making me,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Can we make it a combo?
Care can.
Did you want them?
Yes,
please.
Linkedin tells an extra napkins because I need to wipe down.
Uh,
I think that's it.
So see it on the screen here.
Oh,
what's the total?
Seven 32 oh,
I really like that.
Okay.
Wow.
That sounds good.
Thanks Mommy.
Wow.
Talk about a medley.
That's Landon,
Landon,
and that was old school.
You got in so many good ones.
Yeah.
Fucking camp.
That's an original.
Dennis helpful.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean he went back in the vaults on the references there.
Yeah.
You're a real die hard mommy if you knew some of those.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's really old school.
I can't even fly out.
I can't,
I don't even fucking camp that.
That is so deep in the soundboard.
Yeah.
Fucky camp.
That's a girl that has Tourette's,
by the way.
If you don't,
we don't know that reference.
Yeah.
And uh,
and she's talking about camp and she goes,
sometimes I say swears,
you know,
like fucking camp.
No,
she says big words.
Oh,
she says big ones.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She goes,
sometimes I say big words like good,
like the,
yeah.
I think the worthy Christina always like,
and I don't always say that.
I'm like,
well,
she says first thing in the morning.
Oh my God.
She makes the sign of the cross and all those big words.
Yeah.
That's the girl that says fucking camp.
It's for,
people don't know puck.
Where'd it go?
I really don't know.
Fucking camp.
She's so,
she's so upset about camp.
It's so funny.
Yeah.
And then I said these words.
These words.
Unreal.
Wow.
That guy really got them all in.
Yeah.
She goes,
yeah.
How's good?
What's it called,
man?
I just thought,
oh yeah,
he did.
He said,
um,
I really liked
that price.
Gosh.
Yeah.
So good.
I really liked that.
Linkedin is helpful.
I was old school too,
like this,
this got so popular doing these,
might as well tell you guys
that we did.
We did it.
Hey,
thanks.
Jeans shirt.
It has logos from some of the more popular,
um,
a drive Thru establishments,
but it all,
it has,
you know,
kind of different names on it.
So there's Burger,
burger genes.
It says eat trash in the subway logo,
overpriced coffee.
It says,
what does the term toxic Taco Bell?
It says parties for Arby's.
It says pullout burger for in and out.
It says Tina's Chris Jr for Carl's your mom's House for Mickey D's.
And Tommy's old fashioned laughs for Wendy's.
Um,
and I think she's got a beard.
It looks like.
Here's what we did to it because of,
uh,
that shirt snafu.
We actually upgraded to a tribe land,
which is the,
which is the really soft shirts.
So this is a really,
really soft shirt.
And,
uh,
it says,
hey,
mommy thinks it's a super insider shirt,
so,
uh,
it's on sale.
Check it out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com click on the store and the link will take you to our
merge page.
And,
um,
anyways,
it's really cool.
We had a lot of fun designing it.
We did.
We got a lot of laughs out of this one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So there's a lot of fun.
Yeah.
We've been very excited about this.
About hey mommy.
Thanks genes.
So silly.
Yeah,
that's funny though.
I feel like if you do these,
you should buy one,
your journey.
It's absurd.
So silly.
They hug.
Where can I have Jesus?
A veggie burger from my Degan vagina and just like the guys.
Yeah.
Veggie Burger.
Um,
no man knows.
Like the gays.
Um,
two large fries.
Actually.
Would you,
uh,
would you ever date your son?
Just make it,
just make that one.
Oh,
that was good.
Yeah,
A large coke too actually.
So it's just making a meal,
you know what I'm saying?
And that was a large coke.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to be off you a just a minute.
Top Dog.
I'm just glassing
what was that?
Uh,
just Gladson for a minute.
Um,
let me get a medium water too.
I got to stay hydrated and a,
do you guys have a double pipe?
Classic.
So the double pipe classes,
you might not have it here.
Um,
that's okay.
It's extremely rare.
So I take it you guys probably have the Cincinnati
far either.
Wow.
The Cincinnati for House Naughty Party.
Oh,
nevermind.
That'll do it Monday.
The poster.
Neti,
Neti target.
Fucking fun.
It's probably,
we don't have the Cincinnati fired either.
The one,
the Cincinnati forward.
How's the Nazi party?
Oh No,
nevermind.
Ah,
AH,
that'll do it.
Mommy.
Every second.
Eight.
Okay.
All right.
Thanks jeans.
Wow.
Well that was brilliant when she goes,
when he says,
would you ever,
would you ever date your son?
Yeah.
She goes,
whoa.
Is that goes?
Yeah.
You take one.
That was a really brilliant,
everybody coming to people.
Hitler's ridiculous.
No,
no.
Hey,
health law.
Um,
could I get the mic feast a meal?
Uh,
normal.
no.
Can I get a medium with a water?
I want to stay hydrated.
Like Mommy.
Tina.
Yes.
Um,
and then that's it.
Blood
66.
Great,
thanks James.
66.
I like how they say normal.
They say this is a South African,
right?
Yeah,
I know.
I'm not sure.
That sounds like I said that African act normal.
Yeah.
Are,
are they don't say supersized right.
Not your normal.
True.
Good job,
Ken.
That's fantastic.
Wow.
Really good work.
Hey Mommy,
do you have 50 piece nugget meal?
Oh,
in that case,
can I get a 20 piece nuggets and a handler?
What'd you want?
Um,
um,
big men.
And can I get the Big Mac?
Uh,
can I get honey mustard please hang up.
Hold on.
I'm just glancing.
Uh,
let me get a,
I liked the dodge fried
logical,
a standard response.
Now it's just glass too.
When they go,
is there anything else you go,
just give me some good glasses.
Can we start again?
Yeah.
It kind of worked out nicely to everybody says it and the,
it seems like everybody who's on the other end of that goes like,
okay,
they understand that one there,
you know,
hey,
Hitler is also kind of a natural greeting,
but it's really interesting.
But you would never think that you will have a shirt for that.
I don't think we're going to be selling that.
People have asked and I'm like,
hm,
we should really,
I think it will leave Hitler alone.
Uh,
I think that's it.
So not that like for,
uh,
yeah,
that's it.
Can I get a total please?
I love when people say that we did.
Okay.
Thanks.
Genes by,
that's good.
Mommy thinks Ge,
manly.
Jimmy.
Hey,
genes are the smoked butterscotch.
Can you get that in the Venti?
Yeah.
Can I get that high and tight?
All right.
That's how likes saw him out to get it that way.
That was a silly short and sweet and silly.
And he said,
I die.
And she's like,
yeah.
Yeah,
Jimmy.
Thanks Jamie.
Job.
Now the 50 piece nugget.
I'm curious how long that lasted.
That sounds disgusting.
Sounds like a lot.
It's two 50 no,
that's too much.
I like a nugget.
Don't get me wrong,
but fit five olds.
That's tough.
Thanks.
I'll just gloss for a minute.
Then it in your buckets,
what quantities do they come in?
Hey talking chicken.
Yeah,
chicken.
I honest.
The Arcane Wiki pieces of five nine 12 1521 but in like the family buckets and
stuff,
we have the mega fees,
which is 12 and then the mega bucket,
which is 15 no,
I don't want to be fat log bit.
Um,
okay.
So did you say a 12th is that what okay.
Yeah.
Any chips or anything?
No,
no.
I don't want to be skinny like Tom.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Just a 12 bucket would be cool.
The trial cases and full of sources.
Do you do any mushy purple's no,
I'm sorry.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
yeah,
I think that'd be it.
Onsite
traveling three.
Okay.
Thanks Molly.
Great.
That's Dave.
Good job Dave.
And I like the use of subtitles there.
Yeah,
she purple breaking it down for us.
He's like,
they don't know if these accents going on.
That's true.
Isn't one.
Where else
can I get a lunch?
She's like a meal with the
press.
Another cheeseburger.
Yep.
That's it.
Amaze.
Thanks Jean.
Yeah.
Short.
Right?
We can't keep up with them now.
No,
we can't.
There's too many.
It's funny.
It's this.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
I got to get the shirt to commemorate the movement.
That's so funny.
Um,
God damn.
We're building a wall.
We all keep the motherfuckers out.
That's my favorite thing.
My favorite thing of the year so far.
Yeah,
I know you don't like it.
Building the wall.
Tow Yard a while was cup.
I'm telling y'all motherfuckers out.
We'd run into industry now.
We are running the industry now
so much.
Uh,
shit man.
Um,
what's this here?
I think I have to shit.
We'll see.
Is this you?
He didn't even hear it.
Drinking water on stage.
That's in Atlanta.
Biking a bottle.
I've done that too.
That's just for show.
Where's your water now?
Interesting.
We've been shooting this show for the last name.
Tom.
Seriously?
Do you see that crowd,
mom nuts?
Where's your water?
Right.
And that's why
that's been,
excuse me,
but where's your water right now?
Here's the thing.
I told him and he told me,
I drink so much water.
Actually need to dial it back a little bit.
I have a refreshing glass right here and I don't see yours.
Isn't that something?
You know you're definitely not interesting.
The memory champion.
Why?
Because your memory.
Sex.
Yeah.
So what?
I didn't never sleep anymore.
I did.
You have a kid.
It's gone.
We just wanted to say there's just one more thing.
Yeah,
I don't have a good memory.
So what?
You're the memory champ.
Fine.
Okay.
I'm the personality champ.
No,
you're not in the water champ.
No.
Everybody knows it.
Everybody says it.
MMM.
No,
no,
no.
What else?
I'm the smile champ.
My teeth are much better than yours.
The doctor said so.
The doctor gave me an a.
What was your goal?
Your grade?
February 9th Oh my God.
You're just going to ignore me.
I will be at the House of Blues in Las Vegas.
If you live in Vegas,
Holler at your boy.
If you're planning a trip to Vegas that week,
it's going to be a lot of fun.
Come on out.
House of Blues.
Man,
I'm bringing the full charge.
It'll be a good time.
That Sunday,
February 12th,
we are doing the podcast live at the Irvine Improv in Irvine,
California.
Two shows.
We're going to do two different podcasts live seven and nine.
The seven o'clock is sold out,
so we added a nine o'clock and then that one,
Yoshi Obayashi is joining us.
That'll be really fun.
If you've never heard the Yoshi episodes and you're around,
you should come see him live.
And those tickets are going fast too by the way,
are moving.
Get them now.
My tour continues.
If you go to Tom cigarette.com/tour,
uh,
you can get tickets.
I know a bunch of shows of soda.
I think Edmonton sold out.
I don't know if Calgary still has tickets.
I'm doing Huntington,
New York,
which is Long Island Mont at Atlantic city.
All of them are like right on the verge of selling out if they're not sold out.
Vancouver,
um,
sold out a couple in Chicago.
We added a show.
We added a show in Detroit at Royal Oak and we added a show in Boston.
So,
uh,
get tickets now or you'll miss out.
Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour jeans.
Alright.
In addition to February 12th with my lover,
my para more Tom,
if that'd be wary.
17th.
I'm at the Hollywood Improv,
headlining that show.
Uh,
my friend Mary Lynn Rice cub is joining Steve Simone,
uh,
hold on.
Oh,
February 18th flappers comedy club,
headlining that to the next night.
Uh,
April 13th through 15th.
Braya Improv.
May 4th through fifth.
Phoenix,
Arizona.
Standup live May 19th through 20th.
Jude ORC titties,
Gotham comedy club.
June one through third.
I've just added Denver,
Denver comedy works downtown brothers June 1st through third.
So come see me in Denver.
And then June 16th or 17th man friend disco at the punchline.
Comedy Club tickets@thousandranch.com.
That's it.
Hmm.
I love it.
Um,
all right.
That's a fun show.
Jeans.
Yeah.
Uh,
we should get going.
Okay.
You want to go get some Korean food?
Fuck,
I'm dying.
Please hurry.
Let's go.
All right.
Thank you guys for listening.
Please check out your mom's house,
podcast.com and we'll be back again next week.
We love you.
We thank you.
Goodbye genes by Mommy's.
Thank you,
John McAfee,
John Maxwell,
John Matches
at Chucky as
checkbooks,
all anything.
John,
that
John McAfee,
John John,
John,
John McAfee,
John Back,
John,
back to be.